let's hear more from russell wilson from
yesterday's dan patrick show on this
question of whether or not he's
available in trade here he is
what do you make of uh cbs jason locke
and forrest saying that seattle had
gotten you know calls for uh possible
you know
trade talks with you do you believe that
that uh seattle has gotten calls
yeah i definitely believe they've gotten
calls for sure i didn't think that uh
you know i think anytime you're um you
know
you know a player that you know tries to
produce every week and has done it for
you know consistently i think people are
going to call for sure and i think it's
part of the process yeah but you're a
franchise quarterback you're a hall of
fame quarterback you're not available
are you
well i'm not sure if i'm available or
not that's a that's a question
that's a seahawks question well he he
does have some input because he has a no
trade clause so it's not like they can
just send him wherever they want to send
him he's got the same power that deshawn
watson has to put the kibosh on whatever
it is the seahawks may choose to do if
and when they want to trade him if they
ever get to that point
i i just there's there's a vibe there
there is a vibe i agree wilson i agree
that we've never seen before
from a quarterback
franchise level with a team speaking
that bluntly now he can get away with it
he's kind of like patrick mahomes in
that regard where you can say the candid
thing out loud
and it's not something that is going to
piss people off sorry
london it's the kind of thing
that that is part of the overall
charisma of the athlete and mahomes and
wilson can pull it off i don't know that
brady could pull it off i don't think
rogers can pull it off i think rogers is
afraid to try to pull it off because he
doesn't want to end up being brett favre
level pariah right in green bay i think
that's one of the reasons why he stays
away i think it's again to get back to
what we were politely debating earlier i
think that's one of the reasons why he
opts for subtle messages that he doesn't
want the media to lock on to because he
doesn't want to start down that path of
getting packers fans up in arms about
rogers may dare consider
choosing to leave at some point but
that was that was
there's a lot there and i think what you
need to take away from it if you're a
seahawks fan is they got one year to get
this right i i i don't think it's traded
this no doubt they got one year yeah one
more year to get it right yeah he's
putting the pressure on him there's no
doubt about that mike and you know your
pasta and meatball's gut has been been
all over this for
i don't know i feel like you've been
saying this for three weeks that there
might be something there and i don't
know what put it on your radar but
you've been saying it and yesterday's
quotes yes you you say what you want i
like russell wilson but he sure
obviously showed
that there are some issues there that he
would like to get figured out with the
seattle seahawks and if i'm a seahawks
fan i'm not mad at him i'm trying to i'm
trying to be objective and disconnect
myself from it and say if i was a
seahawks fan how would i react to what
russell wilson said would i be i i
definitely would be disappointed i'd be
mad i'd have that feeling in my gut that
we're entering into a protracted period
of not being very good that there's
issues now that aren't going to be easy
to resolve who am i blaming well
maybe i'm blaming the team
for not putting enough around him
and it's easy for me to feel that way if
i'm a seahawks fan because yeah i could
be saying we should have more
championships than we do that russell
wilson isn't the problem now at some
level the quarterback's fingerprints are
on the success or lack thereof yeah but
but if you're not letting the guy have a
say in in in who they bring in and how
they manage the team then he can't say
it's all on him no and you can't you
definitely cannot and russell wilson and
this is the perfect example too because
like we talked about we know what kind
of coach they have in the organization
and he can easily sit there and go
listen organization
you want to do it this way
i've been doing my part
you know we've been doing this run basic
offense play defense type of thing and
you guys haven't been holding up your
end of the bargain i'm holding up my end
i i'm doing i'm throwing 35 touchdown
passes and seven or eight interceptions
every year in a basic offense and doing
all that you know he might be saying hey
we tried your way it's got to change a
little bit and i know people are going
to go well they tried you know in russ
we trust and let russ cook all that
stuff this year
yeah okay
you called more drop back passes
it didn't mean
they went all in on it you know not from
the plays i watched on film all year and
everything like that they just called
pass plays it didn't mean like last
offseason they grew their offense and
all of a sudden had all these new
concepts and i was like whoa seattle
changed no they just went hey usually we
run it on first and ten let's throw it
that was their change this year and russ
was awesome because he is awesome but
like you mentioned and we mentioned a
lot during the year the nfl caught on to
what they do very quickly and then it
becomes all about the jimmies and the
joes and the x's and o's do nothing for
them and then it becomes all about
russell wilson having to throw dimes and
dk metcalf you know having to beat
double coverages or you know running
predictable routes that the defense
knows what he's going to run but he's
still got to get open and russell's
still got to hit him and that's where i
think russell's frustrated and i
understand that because he's being held
to a standard of like you're saying you
know greatness status and we're
comparing him to all these other guys
and he's sitting there going yeah like i
love that i'm being compared but it's
not freaking fair it's not fair that i'm
being compared because i don't have some
of the things i need to compete with you
know tom brady's of the top guys and
things like that
russell wilson has a habit of signing
four-year extensions entering the final
year of
his pending contract and one of the
intriguing dynamics here that should not
be overlooked is the fact that his agent
mark rogers is a baseball agent who has
one
football client he's the nfl's
equivalent of tom hagan he has a very
specialized practice i like tom here's
here's how that becomes a factor here's
how that becomes a factor
if you're an agent who has players
throughout the league or more
importantly other players on the
seahawks or other players that may want
to play for the seahawks may need a job
may need leverage may need whatever
if you have other clients that are going
to be doing business potentially with
this team and with other teams you can
only push so far without potentially
undermining your relationship
with the seahawks with other teams
there's a limit there's a line that you
can't cross because you've got broader
business interest that could be
compromised if you piss everybody off
sorry london yeah
by by driving the hardest possible
bargain
for your superstar quarterback that's
just the way it works folks that's how
the sausage gets made
mark rogers doesn't have those issues he
doesn't have those burdens he doesn't
have those potential factors that could
affect his ability
to drive the hardest possible bargain he
can for russell wilson look at what he
gets you know these teams five years six
year ten year extension four years
four years bare minimum
and it's always market value
after the
first three years of russell wilson's
career going into the 20 12 13 14 15
season
right yeah you get market value yeah
next time around 2019 going into the
last year of that extension that four
year extension what'd he get market
value 35 million more than anybody else
so what's coming there's three years
left on his contract now
the pattern would be that it's going to
come two years from now i think it's
going to happen next year i think next
year is the up or out moment where
the seahawks and rogers get together
whether the seahawks want to or not and
the conversation's going to be
we want this guy to be the highest paid
quarterback in football or
he wants to move on yeah and i think
that comes next year right and and the
seahawks are going to have to decide how
much money do we want to invest in the
quarterback position remembering that
they got to the super bowl to back years
with what chris a third round yucky
right cocky right at quarterback right
and we've seen a lot of other
quarterbacks go to the super bowl and
rookie contracts too here the last you
know few years so it's a real thing and
again let's not forget we talked about
it this spring
no it's true
i mean the the the the seattle seahawks
called the cleveland browns a few years
ago and tried to get russell wilson for
the number one pick
so you know there this is a weird
quarterback franchise marriage here it
always has been it really has been that
way and mike your point about the agent
thing is very real i'm glad you brought
that up it is you know again i had a guy
like tom condon you know who was a major
power player right you know
teams couldn't mess with tom condon they
couldn't mess with them as it pertained
to me because they'd go well wait he's
got two other superstars on our team and
he can make life really hard on us the
next time if we screw over chris sims or
do that that's the why you want a great
agent now superstars sometimes don't
need that because they can just you know
be on their own
um so that that the flip side of it is
if you decide to go scorched earth if
brandon
earth on behalf of his one superstar or
one of his superstars because he does
represent many of them right that can
come back and bite you with other guys
no balance there there's no dead spot
rogers doesn't have to care about that
sweet spot no you're right you're you're
right about that now the other thing i
find interesting about yesterday we
haven't hit on this and i don't mind i
hope you don't mind if we go there but i
i do you know we have i think we have
the brandon marshall quote yes or
whatever absolutely yeah yeah i find
those interesting and let me just just
preface it first i find it interesting
because first off brandon marshall
doesn't speak like this often this is
not what he does
so
he must know something and
he played and went up and played for the
seattle seahawks at one point so i would
think he's getting this right from the
horse's mouth or somebody that is in
direct knowledge here
the dk metcalf comments from a week or
two ago oh that he was with him right
what am i
remember what we said all that stuff dk
metcalf saying he's only been there two
seasons he's not coming to these
conclusions on his own he's not doing
his story
on the seahawks right someone's telling
him yeah and it's russ that's telling
him so here's what brandon marshall said
yesterday on first things first on fs1
russell wilson is beyond
frustrated i think russell wilson is
trying to figure out
how to move on
in a classy way
i know they don't believe in russ i
think russ wants to stay think about i
know they don't believe
in russ
i think russ wants to stay there but he
knows pete carroll is going to continue
to give him the runaround and i just
think it's getting to a point where russ
just
doesn't
believe
yeesh
wow
so that's where we are yeah i know an
avalanche of pr yeah that is putting the
seahawks in a corner to the point where
they got to say something at some point
chris they just can't keep their head
down and keep moving they got to say
something yeah probably they do i mean
it's gotten to a point now yes it's
going to be talked about all morning and
all talk shows and things like that you
know i'll i'll say this
you know i uh brandon i'm sure has very
good knowledge of the situation just
like we mentioned there's just too many
dots to connect there to think not and
like we said he's he's not not really
this guy that tries to be johnny you
know news breaker so that would tell me
he really knows this you know the part i
find interesting is you know the
organization doesn't believe in him
either or that whatever that quote was
similar to that
um
i you know i don't know if i buy that
they don't believe in russ
i don't believe they buy into
playing through the quarterback and
really doing that right
so that plays it yes that's the point
and that's the issue and i think that's
where russell wilson's trying to have a
little bit of a culture war and that's
where it's also going to be interesting
with shane waldron coming to town from
the rams who yes it sounds like russ had
some say in that
but
shane's a lot like the guys they've had
i mean yeah okay he does it a little
different way because of the mcvay thing
and all that but it's still run and boo
legs and play action
and
i i i got i don't know about the drop
back pass game to me that's one of the
question marks of the rams offense is it
mcveigh is it jared goff i think it's a
little bit of both i'd like to see more
there so i'm interested to see how that
plays out and how shane waldron can
really impress himself you know upon
russell wilson too
and
again this is all part of the
one more year i believe i don't think
they're going to trade him now they
definitely wouldn't trade him well i
can't say definitely about anything who
the hell knows they take a 39 million
cap charge if they trade him before june
1. they could hold him until after june
1 because what there's not going to be
an off season program anyway i mean
who
they could do a tentative deal to be
effective after june one and he could go
spend
march april and may working out with his
future teammates on their own away from
team facility and prepare for the season
that way there's all sorts of things you
can do in this new world that we live in
but i think it's more likely that next
year there would be a trade and the one
team when you look at how the planets
are lining up
in dallas
and you got one more year with dak
prescott and you got a 37 million dollar
franchise tag for this year and next
year
it goes up 44 it's 53 million plus if
they wanted to tag them again next year
i think the cowboys are just now points
bet disagrees they put the odds together
and this is fascinating to me that the
team do we have the full screen there
the team that apparently is at the top
of the list
is the los angeles rams which tells me
that
if he's not in seattle okay that tells
me oh las vegas yeah i saw lar i thought
that was los angeles rams lost it's lvr
pete lvr maybe pete is a cat lvr
uh so
so i i so plus 450 that he'd play for
the raiders i don't know that he'd want
to deal with john gruden uh but at least
at least john groot would be able to
look him in the eye without standing on
a step ladder but uh
uh sorry but uh look down dallas is
there too at plus 650. jacksonville plus
750 i guess the speculation is he'd be
traded for the first overall pick in the
draft i don't see that either no i i
think that that these are premature
because i think next year is the year i
think it has next year i just and what
would i would if at all well if at all
you're right i don't think i don't see
it happening this year either i don't
you're right too many you know
too many words
weird circumstances with with this
offseason and everything like that too
and
you know i'd i'd wanna i i certainly
don't think i'd want to get rid of
russell wilson right now if i'm the
seattle seahawks they're they're very
close
they're closest so far
i i think in a lot of ways they are yeah
the way their defense played in the last
half of the year you know i think
there's a lot of good pieces in place
here to where
i wouldn't want to abandon ship on where
we are right now no it's not perfect but
i look at them in a pretty good spot
overall uh yeah i don't think they're
that far off
no let me just say this before we take a
break if this truly is part of a
concerted effort
engineered by russell wilson to force
the seahawks to do something sooner than
later number one it's brilliant because
it's not coming off as being engineered
but you know we mentioned brandon
marshall i
i think russell's smart enough to know
that if you load up brandon marshall
with some of this stuff he'll unload go
say something right he's going to go say
something and i think the guy to watch
next is jamal adams
i think once jamal adams starts weighing
in like i'm not going to sign an
extension until i know where russell's
going to be once we hear that that tells
me that jamal's been recruited to join
the effort as well so
uh
look
the the offseason was going to be
compelling without this story
hitting full boil now where the seahawks
go from here still could push it to full
boil it could get to the point where
it's untenable it could get to the point
where even though next year makes more
sense
they've got to do something now
and the bottom line is look what would
happen i don't think it's a coincidence
that the loch and for a blurb comes out
monday night and then the next day
russell wilson's on dan patrick bearing
his soul
about the things that he wants in a way
that frankly chris we've never heard a
quarterback talk right no i i know it's
uh i don't think it's you know a
coincidence either i i don't i think
russell's too
tactical and smart uh he understands how
to answer all the questions we know that
we've seen it firsthand i mean he's very
good that way and i think yes this is a
message that he intended to
you know shoot shoot up into the sky so
the seattle seahawks and the rest of the
country could read it and try to talk
about it and put the pressure on the
seattle seahawks
and that aaron rodgers is how you go
about sending a message to the team if
you want to send a message to the team
well why was that any better tell me
what like we're talking about it and now
it's an off-season issue so that's
better i mean i don't you're
okay i'm just saying if you want to send
a message to the team just send a
message to the team he does he says it
blatant it's flat out we didn't have
energy on the sideline today i mean
what's wrong with that it's flat out it
doesn't get any more freaking flat out
than that but but chris chris you're
proving my point when he said in 2016 we
didn't have energy on the sideline today
and i say he's taking a shot at mike
mccarthy he says don't waste your time
reading that crap that that guy oh he's
not going to catch you pitted against
that that's my point no he's not going
to let you put it again thank you
russell wilson we'll be back to talk
this segment after this our longest
first segment ever at 40 minutes we'll
be back with more pft live right
afterwards
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports